okay so let's get right to it there's
been some changes at Y Combinator yeah
that you timed perfectly before this
speaking gig thank God to make sure we
have to get that announcement done by
the by before the launch conference
thank you kidding exactly what exactly
is the announcement and and how does it
change why comedy oh my god and your
role yeah here's a picture you can throw
up you know who you know who that is
that Sam Altman Alexis Steve Huffman and
Justin and Emmett from twitch Wow and
everybody in that picture now works for
Y Combinator in some way except Steve
Huffman that's amazing what you're is
that that's the first batch that is the
first summer that is probably a demo of
Reddit judging by where the way people
are standing that is probably a demo of
an early version of Reddit and I see you
kept the same shirt and you know it
might it might well be actually is that
nine years ago that's that's the summer
of 2005 yeah
in Boston yeah in Cambridge and Sam
Altman all the way on the left with the
blue shirt who did you cooped yeah which
was the first really mobile
location-aware
product yeah kinda sad people didn't
want to broadcast their locations people
want a consume location but they don't
want to supply it interesting and now
you've made him the president of Y
Combinator yeah he is gonna be the boss
I'm not running the show anymore it's
Sam's show now why is that we just tired
after nine years and 600 startups yeah I
think you do have I think you said in
your piece that you thought he would do
a better job why well what's your
thinking Y Combinator's can I have two
grow right we grow as the number of
startups grows and the number of
startups has been growing um
and Y Combinator it's like this it
started out you saw what it was like it
was just that was in my kitchen that
picture and now we've got like 10
full-time partners maybe 20 people total
and I mean no exactly six hundred and
thirty two startups we funded it's
turned into this giant thing and
no good at running giant things Sam
however is gonna be good at running a
giant thing and are you going to be
involved every day or a couple of days
or to be determine because that was
something that I think a lot of people
weren't clear about you said you're
gonna do office hours I'm gonna do
office hours with the startups but I
don't do office hours every day right so
probably I'll end up doing office hours
a couple days a week that will probably
be enough to talk to everybody in each
batch and other than that I'm not doing
anything I'm not reading applications
I'm not doing interviews I'm not
worrying about all the hideous internal
crap that takes up the time of most
organizations it the founders in each
batch they see me at office hours and as
far as they're concerned that's what I
do that's about a tenth of what I do I
spend all the rest of my time dealing
with random crap associated with any
anything of any size so now I won't so
it'll look the same to the founders
right but it will feel very different to
me